بعد 14 يومًا ، كنا متجهين إلى
المغادرة بعد أسبوعين من
الحجر الصحي ، يشعر الفريق بأكمله بالرضا
عن استمرارنا نحن الثلاثة زينا
والمصورة الصحفية ناتالي توماس
المنتجة جونغ تشونغ وانتهى بي الأمر
هنا بسبب المكان الذي كنا فيه قبل أسبوعين.
كان تسجيل الخروج من الفندق أكثر إرهاقًا ،
وكان هذا هو الساعة 3:30 صباحًا في طريقنا إلى
محطة القطار التي خططنا لها لبضعة
أيام في ووهان ، ولكن رن الهاتف لمدة 29 ساعة
كانت المدينة في حالة إغلاق
وكنا بحاجة إلى الخروج في الوقت الحالي
لم نتمكن حقًا من تخيل مدى ضخامة هذا الأمر الذي
سيؤدي إلى فرض قيود الإغلاق على الملايين مما يؤدي إلى
ارتفاع عدد القتلى بسرعة
عشرات الآلاف من المصابين
وعزل الصين القارية أساسًا عن
بقية العالم ، وكنا في الحلقة
قررت سي إن إن علينا العودة إلى بكين
والحد على الفور  التعرض
للآخرين ولكننا ما زلنا نرغب في سرد
صة ولدينا 350 قدمًا مربعًا للقيام بذ
ك ، لذا لا يمكن للتنقل السيئ من غرفة نومي إل
غرفة المعيشة أو استوديوهاتنا بشكل أس
سي  حتى أن نفعل ذلك بالنعال ،
فهذه هي الخلفية التي حصلنا عليها
هنا وهي تتساقط اليوم ، ونحن بين
التقارير الحية أجرينا الكثير من الأبحاث
لتوجيه منتجنا ولكن على الهاتف يعمل الكثير
من مصادره في ووهان ومن مقاطعة باي على
وجه الخصوص في  بين
بعض تقاريرنا ، كانت ناتالي وراء الكاميرا
يفعلون الشيء نفسه عندما لم نكن
على الهواء ، كنا مستغرقين في الحصول على
قصة ، قد تتحقق روسيا من واحد اثنين ثلاثة
ولكن بصراحة ما زلنا نشعر
بالذنب بعض الشيء لأننا مشينا  بعيدًا عن
سكان ووهان ، فقد أثرت بشكل خاص على
الشباب وناتالي كونهم
صينيين وناتالي بعد أن وصفت هذا البلد
بالمنزل منذ ما يقرب من عقد من الزمان بالنسبة لهم ، كان الأمر
شخصيًا ، لذلك عملنا طوال ساعات إما
الدردشة بالفيديو أو الاتصال بالعشرات من
الأشخاص الذين ما زالوا في ووهان يونغ للتركيز
جهوده على الطبيب الذي حاول
دق ناقوس الخطر
مبكرًا على تعلم ناتالي من
العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية حول الحاجة الماسة
للإمدادات القرار الكبير
خدمة غرف وجباتنا ولكن فقط لتكون آمنًا على
ntire stay لم نسمح لموظفي الفندق
بالدخول إلى غرفنا وبدا أنهم
جيدون مع ذلك بمجرد أن طرقوا طرقنا
، فتحنا وانسحبوا إلى القاعة
حتى مع بضع ساعات من النوم كل
ليلة كنا نشبع بالأدرينالين
للحفاظ على  لأكون صادقًا ، حفزتني ناتالي والشباب على
الاعتراف بأننا
أخذنا ليلة واحدة للاسترخاء ، لقد كانت
ليلة رأس السنة الصينية الجديدة وكان من المهم
حقًا للشباب ولكن بعد ذلك العودة إلى العمل حتى
استيقظ
وقتنا اليوم 14 ، كل شيء يعود إلى
ما كان عليه  ونحن الآن نتوجه إلى
بكين الثلجية ولكن الكتلة في هذا الوقت
تخرج إلى هواء بكين المتجمد
قافزًا في
السيارة ونواصل سعينا وراء هذه القصة
حتى بعد ما يقرب من عقدين من الزمان تقريبًا
مريض السارس السابق أليكس لام الذي طاردته
تجربته التي وضعت فيها  غرفة كبيرة بها
العديد من المرضى الآخرين ، سمعت بعض
السعال في الليل يبكي وهذا أمر
محزن حقًا
سارس أصاب حوالي 8000 شخص على
مستوى العالم وقتل 774 نصفهم تقريبًا
في هونغ كونغ أدى عزل الحالات في
النهاية  حتى نهاية
تفشي المرض ، كان تفشي فيروس كورونا الجديد
بالفعل أكبر من سارس ، وقد تم
اتخاذ تدابير غير مسبوقة
للسيطرة عليه ، والبناء السريع
للمستشفيات ، والإنتاج الضخم
للإمدادات الطبية ومعدات الحماية ،
وقيود السفر الشاملة
وفحوصات درجة الحرارة ، متى ستوقف هذه
الإجراءات  تفشي المرض بشكل جيد
تكمن الإجابة في فهم الفيروس
نفسه داخل هذا المبنى وهو
أول نسخة مخبرية من
فيروس كورونا خارج البر الرئيسي للصين ، إنه
اختراق كبير يسمح
للباحثين هنا في جامعة هونغ كونغ
بفهم سلوك
الفيروس بشكل أفضل داخل الصين.  مختبر نحن مطالبون
بارتداء أقنعة الوجه ، أشعر
أن هذا سيكون مثل سيلاس
هو أن العالم سيصاب
بنزلة برد شديدة لمدة خمسة أشهر تقريبًا ولكن
مع تحذير رئيسي واحد ، يبدو أن الفيروس الجديد
على عكس السارس يمكن  ينتشر قبل
ظهور الأعراض ولكن المشكلة مع
هذا الفيروس أنه يظهر
أنه يوجد ملف
فترة خلال الأيام الأربعة أو الخمسة الأولى حيث يقول الناس إنهم يمكن أن يكونوا أثناء القراءة ولكن ربما لا تظهر عليهم أعراض ، ولهذا السبب سيكون من الصعب جدًا إدارتها ، لكن هذا يحدث أثناء تفشي المرض ، لذا فإن الأقنعة قد أزيلت عندما أكون قابل مالك باريس في مكتبه ، وهو يقدم المشورة لمنظمة الصحة العالمية بشأن الفيروس ، ويقول إن هناك سيناريوهين متطرفين يتم فيه السيطرة على تفشي المرض أو أنهما الحد الأقصى بالطبع هو أن الفيروس يشبه الإنفلونزا مما يعني أنه لا يمكن احتواؤه و سينتشر هذا وقد حدث بالفعل مع h1n1 المعروف أيضًا باسم إنفلونزا الخنازير ، ظهرت السلالة في جائحة في عام 2009 وهي الآن فيروس موسمي ولكن بالنسبة لأليكس لام البشرية لا تحتاج إلى مرض آخر لمواجهته ، يجب أن نقف معًا نحتاج إلى التفكير إيجابي لأنه في يوم من الأيام سيختفي المرض الآن. رئيس مجموعة من الناجين من السارس في هونغ كونغ يدعو الحكومة إلى اتخاذ تدابير أكثر صرامة مهما كان الأمر.  إنهاء أحدث
اندلاع كريستي لو ستاوت سي إن إن هونغ كونغ